[Music]
yo what's up guys it's your boy cute and
I want to welcome you to musical dares
the show we play a classic game of
musical chairs those dares in there make
people use some disgusting let's have a
good time today y'all I want to
introduce y'all to our guests my name is
Aaron I've watched in the fear factor in
my life to not be scared of any dare
that's thrown my way so I'm ready to win
my name's Andrew and I'm taking this
home come on give me the trophy now what
I win
where's the money yet what's up my
name's Stanley I'm ready to sit mr.
chair but I didn't know how to eat some
brush don't see how that goes hey guys
my name is Lea I don't think I actually
remember signing up for this but I've
met a lot of weird things in my day I
don't see how that's not excited my name
is top rope Zeus I am a MC see that's
musical chair champion of 1998 Norview
elementary school feel good all right
those are contestants they awesomely
they're pretty competitive
let's get to this game the rules of
musical dares are simple we have four
chairs three of the chairs of white and
one of the chairs is red the Reds here
is the Dare chair if the music stops and
you land in the Dare chair or don't get
a chair at all you're either gonna be
eating some discussing or you'll be
headed home for the day winner gets 150
dollars cash or a special grand prize
let's get into this first wrong people
and positions everybody the first saw
let's get it going oh good bust out the
chairs the music hey stop
[Music]
look serious oh yeah okay okay I know
buddies you know my let it dance okay
yeah yeah Bailey looks like you are off
the chair of my guy all right guys so
here's the thing we love McDonald's
around here I love McDonald's I mean a
Big Mac one of my favorite things to eat
so what I made for you guys today it's
called the big yak you guys gonna be try
some yak meat you guys know yak is early
it's a giant cow barely it's disgusting
but you guys gonna try today so Leah
since you sat in a chair you have the
decision of whether you want to take a
bite of this yak or if you want to pass
out to Stanley what are you gonna do
well I have not eaten breakfast today
not scared of yak meat it's like a
burger the presentations okay I'll take
a bite Lee let's see it what's up I have
so many questions can I ask questions oh
no really I'll give you one I'll give
you one question who cook this it's from
a very nice Ally it's nature's natural
yak yak meat yeah week Dagny this looks
disgusting this is a big yak I'm a
little nervous about having to have a
two stack of it
you gotta swallow it - if you don't
swallow it don't count that book alright
well this is how this is gonna be I'm
winning this game
oh the confidence okay well listen this
is only the first round it's all getting
worse from here press
all right so Stanley unfortunately
that's gonna be it for you bro Lee is
not afraid of no yak meat I'm need you
to get the hell up out of here - all
right I was round one my boy Stanley is
gone I mean honestly I kind of miss him
man he was a good guy he was a cool guy
but let's move on to round two let's get
to it guys let's get in you gonna slow
it down a little bit okay okay slow the
pace up there music determine the face
[Music]
oh it's making me nervous as hell I am
nervous who was gonna leave this round
me I like all the old man y'all cool it
up somebody got to go Leah
Andrew you guys are safe take a step to
the side Oh Aaron Zeus yeah yeah I know
what's up man this musical dares baby
y'all gonna have to eat something so
disgusting when I was putting together I
didn't even want to look at it man this
is the anchovy latte honestly I don't
know guys just go check it out I don't
want to talk too much about it
Zeus it's your time man Thank You Q you
did the chunk of bottom
well everybody has advice today you know
all right
Cheers
[Music]
Oh Seuss play like a champion always
play like a champion oh how you feeling
man that's like I feel like going home
hi Zeus man well that's it Zeus is not
afraid of an anchovy latte Aaron I am so
sorry he was killing it your dance moves
was on point but I'm sorry you gotta go
we gotta get to the rest of this game I
didn't have to eat anything so I feel
like I'm the real winner here that's a
spirit and I love it alright that was
round two let's getting around three
y'all get back here bring this music up
now oh I like this I like this Oh
[Music]
my hand feeling real quickly at lunch we
go longer Andrew you've been battling it
out oh yeah I got a shove-mucker
oh game Zeus
you're in the white hair bro you are
good to go to the side more anchovies
man Leah
Andrew ya know the game but the
difference is for the third round we
always do a mystery challenge so what
you have to do is act like a frying
piece of bacon in 20 second you have to
act like a frying piece of bacon for 20
seconds can i out bacon her and take her
side yes sir you can't
I've been waiting AG like bacon we got a
bacon off okay let me see we okay okay I
see honestly honestly I've seen enough
I've seen enough I'm I have to give this
one to my man Andrew he made the noises
Andrew that was good man Leah I really
appreciate you putting yourself out
there like that
but when he did the crumbles you took it
I had to give it to him but y'all
appreciate you coming out lady Acme you
show that you really got a lot of heart
but I'm gonna have to ask you get up out
of here cuz we got two final contestants
and somebody gotta get this cash so we
got my boy Zeus we got my boy Andrew hi
out feeling ready to go feel good okay
yeah holidays slagging on it's here okay
okay we get it tricky now look at the
note down is only a nervous I might stop
it on the beat on this one you know just
to make make it real funny like yes
better still okay
[Music]
the iterator move that's how you get the
championships
Zeus here's the thing like you dig it in
the chair but this is the ultimate dare
my friend
wait what I thought I was the winner not
yet the final dare bro we got to level
it up to the top I have this counter and
I really need you to get in there bro
[Music]
all right I mean let me know my man
Andrew looking real hungry man I've been
waiting to eat some tongue all right all
right honestly bro I played like a
champion up to this point I cannot let
my hometown of Norfolk Virginia down my
mother throw up oh oh I was a crunchy
why was it crunchy that's weird that's
weird
mm-hmm King Kong King your mouth that's
what it's all about
honestly I did not think he was gonna do
grab my character now
I appreciate you Dawg you did your thing
beef tongue yeah no yeah listen Zeus is
not afraid to have a good time he's
trying to give this money right yeah
Andrew I appreciate you coming out too
bro
you know how it goes man you got to be
fast if you want music Adair's hey you
gonna eat the rest of this tongue
[Music]